menteur manipulateur les tracteurs de
benyamin nétanyahou ne ménagent pas
leurs mots ils étaient des milliers
d'israéliens à manifester hier soir à
tel aviv contre leur premier ministre
des défilés ont lieu régulièrement
depuis plus d'un mois mais ils sont de
plus en plus nombreux à la proche du
procès de benyamin nétanyahou
ce dimanche le chef de gouvernement
israélien comparaît pour corruption
fraude et abus de confiance dans trois
affaires une première audience avait
lieu en mai dernier
vendredi les manifestants se sont rendus
devant la résidence du premier ministre
pour demander sa démission
nous sommes jeunes les israéliens de
tout le pays nous sommes fatigués de la
corruption du racisme et de la violence
de l'êta gnahou et nous sommes ici pour
dire arrêtez la corruption arrêter la
violence
arrêté le racisme et nous sommes ici
pour protester et dire netanyahu va en
prison rentre chez toi laisse nous tuer
un dictateur nous ne voulons pas de toi
je suis venue manifester pour la justice
et la justice cite aussi que le premier
ministre est accusé de crime et sera
traduit en justice et qu'il cessera de
l'éviter la justice est aussi aidé les
faibles ce gouvernement est complètement
perdue il y à un dictateur qui fait
taire tout le monde et les riches
contrôle la police et le parlement
je pense que tant que nous occupons
d'autres peuples et que nous leur
imposons un régime militaire nous ne
pouvons pas nous attendre à voir un
gouvernement non corrompu avoir un
revenu stable et à vivre dignement comme
des êtres humains
je ne comprends pas comment moi en tant
qu'israélien je peux espérer obtenir mes
droits tant que nous occupons d'autres
peuples
la grogne populaire s'est intensifié
après l'annnonce de nouvelles mesures de
restriction pour ralentir l'épidémie de
covile dix neuf qui regagne du terrain
et à la crise sanitaire s'ajoute la
crise économique le taux de chômage en
israël a bondi dépassons les 20 % selon
un sondage de la chaîne traîne publié
cette semaine 61% des zélés
auteurs se disent mécontents de la
gestion de l'épidémie par benyamin
nétanyahou